my name is Georgie Benedict I'm a
mathematician and associate professor at
University of West Bonilla in person
Czech Republic in my talk I present a
method how to find my computer by
computation in machine precision
mathematical guaranteed lower and upper
estimate for a principal eigenvalue for
boundary value problems for differential
equations and to control the rounding
errors the so called interval arithmetic
is used hello thank you for coming see
that you're interested in interval
arithmetic at least of you so I will
speak about a principal eigenvalue for a
value problem for differential equations
why the principal eigenvalue is
important it's a value of a parameter in
some system for instance mechanical
system which is which can be connected
with some material constants and this
very is important because the
corresponding energy functional is
typically coercive we click our say for
those who know what it is we click are
safe under this principle in value and
above the principal it changes and the
function is not corrosive and the
principal value typically resonance
occurs so that's why the principal
release is important and of course the
principal ID value can be computed
either by hand or in a closed form for
only very simple domains very simple
equations in a more complex situation
you can you can only compute
numerical approximate of the principal
again value and it's good to have
guaranteed lower and upper estimate
because if you have for instance a
guaranteed lower estimate then if the
spectral parameter is under the
guaranteed lower estimate then it's
guaranteed that the functional is for
instance coercive so for that I will I
will show a method how to use interval
arithmetic to compute the guaranteed
estimates so do all of you know interval
arithmetic so just a short interaction
[Music]
so example here if you take this
polynomial of third order the root of
this polynomial is the number three
which means that if I substitute 3 for X
I get 0 and if you do the same with this
polynomial of order 30 and you try to
substitute 1 2 3 4 then you get this so
which one would you guess that it's root
for the one which is actually a root you
get 4 million here at 2 you get minus
8,000
so maybe this is closest to be a root
but it's wrong of course so if you know
how the binary representation of Machine
numbers work then you probably know why
this error is bigger because the the
powers of 3 are more rounded than powers
of 2 that's the reason so we can
increase the precision this was in
standard machine precision with the
double and we can we can increase the
precision for instance 20 digits but we
get something like this
no significant digits can be displayed
so we still know nothing so one of the
possible things you can do is that you
compute instead of machine numbers you
compute with intervals so the number
three will be represented by this these
two numbers the endpoints are machine
numbers and they represent every real
number in this interval so for instance
these two machine numbers represent p
and if you perform any algebraic
operations with intervals then the
result always must contain all possible
results of the of the algebra of the
same algebraic operation with the real
numbers in those intervals so if I use
the same polynomial here and I
substitute the intervals for X then what
these results mean the first interval
doesn't contain zero which proves
mathematically proves that this number 1
is not a root of this polynomial these 3
contain zero so the this numbers 2 3 4
can be roots maybe not maybe yes we
don't know of course from computation in
with Machine numbers you cannot you
cannot you can never know exactly what
the result is because there is always
running so you can only prove for
instance inequalities if you want to
prove that some result is for instance
positive then if the result is the
interval that doesn't contain negative
numbers left left endpoint is positive
then the result must be positive and
it's a proof
we can combine combine it with a higher
precision than the machine precision in
this case you already know that two and
four are not roots and three still can
be rude but you cannot know exactly from
this computation so now the boundary
problems so I will speak about the most
simple example of a boundary value
problem did I know so in one dimension
the differential position will be -
second derivative equals lambda is the
spectral parameter times u the boundary
conditions are - lab boundary conditions
of the interval 0 1 and it can be easily
computed by hand that eigenvalues the
definition is similar for matrices for
instance eigen values our values of
lambda such that there is a solution
which is an eigen function so you can
compute it by hand or in Mathematica
that the eigen functions are of the form
sine of T times some integer multiples
of P so the first smallest or principal
eigen value is P Square you can check it
here that the principal value is sine of
P times T and minus second derivative is
P squared times the same so the
principal value so of course in this
case we don't need an estimate we know
the first value exactly but in America
it's almost 10 P squared and you can see
the principal eigen function but if you
take more complex situation more
dimensions with the general
domaine more general differential
operator may be nonlinear then it cannot
be computed closed-form and it's enough
to take one-dimensional equation with
wait here with T plus cosine of T I
intentionally use combination of
algebraic and transcendent function
because now if you if you try it again
to solve it either by hand or in
Mathematica then you get of course
nothing so even in this quite simple
case you can only have estimates of the
principal function of course the
well-known theory to removal theory says
that if the wave is weight is a
continuous positive function then there
exist a sequence of eigenvalues and they
are positive one of them is smallest
it's the principal value but we cannot
compute it in a closed form so we can
try to compute some estimates so first I
will speak about our estimate the tool
how to prove an app estimate is to use
this so-called variational
characterization of the principal
function that is minimum of this which
is called Rayleigh quotient and the
minimum is taken over all functions from
the subspace W 1 to 0 which means that
it's 0 at the ends and the minimum is
achieved when you when you use for me
the principal ideal function we can
check that if we here the principal the
function we compute the integral
integral of square and of the function
then the ratio is P squared so it's
exactly the the principal value but we
can use n/a for
from the Saburo space and then of course
there is inequality that the Rayleigh
quotient is bigger or equal principal
eigenvalue so if we try some similar
function for instance this quadratic
function V the blue one is the test
function and the orange one is the
principal function so they are quite
similar and you compute the Rayleigh
quotient you get 10 which is pretty
close with now you can do the same for
the non constant wait wait and you get
this number which is numerically this
7.34 something so this is an upper
estimate so the principal value is under
this this value and now the lower
estimates so how to prove lower estimate
it can be proved using pecan identity I
will not go into technical details here
but if you take any test function ve
which now has to be C 2 and positive
inside 0 1 and you find infimum of of
this this term then this number is an
estimate from below its lowest so it's
clear that again if you use the
principal idol function as a test
function then the ratio is constant and
it's the first eigenvalue so that is
equal to the first eigen value to the
principal value and if you use another
so we can use again
the quadratic function then you can
easily compute by hand that the minimum
is 8 and it's achieved at 1/2 of course
8 is more far it's it's a worse estimate
than the estimate from above and it's
typical that it's harder to to prove
some lower estimate than our estimate so
this was for the constant weight or no
weight and we can try again the same
test function with the weight and more
or less by hand can be computed that the
minimum the infimum is around five point
seven six and now we know that the
principal eigen value with the weight is
in this interval it's quite wide and of
course we would like to to make it more
narrow so how do we do that so one of
the possibilities is to use the
numerical approximation of the principal
I can function so by classical shooting
method I compute the numerical
approximation of the of the principal
eigen value and eigen function first so
we get this number seven point two 2/7 I
think but we don't know the error at all
we can believe that it's near but as I
showed at the beginning we cannot know
what the error is of course in a
dissolve there's some accuracy go and
precision goal but it's not guaranteed
mark say then it's true so we cannot
know mathematically what the error is
but what can we do now this is just the
plot of the record proximation of the
Principality function so what can we do
is to use this numerical approximation a
variety at some points and use them as
as control points of a cubic spline
because cubic spline is c2 so it is an
admissible test function it's even in w1
to 0 if it's 0 at the end so I define
here the control points let's see it
here for instance with four subintervals
so for cubic range functions and I will
compute the coefficients of the of the
cubic function by hand I will explain
why there are functions in Mathematica
for that but I will do it by hand so
here I compute the second derivatives at
the inner points and here the
coefficients and this is the spline
function so it's c2 and its admissible
admissible test function and now we can
try to compute an upper estimate so
let's compute this is the Rayleigh
quotient further for the cubic spline so
we would expect that this is an upper
estimate but this is not correct at
least for two reasons so the first one
is that we had some control points we
can take them as precise numbers a very
messy number is also some real number
but for these control points there
exists some interpolation spine with
some coefficients but we computed them
with roundings
so the coefficients are not exact
and if they're on date then of course
the the cubic functions are not even
continuous the control points I used to
get back you mean so in what 44 45 46 46
floor yes that's because it's not
rounding it's because we have four four
cubic functions so we compute here the
index from the array of the perficient's
yes for that reason so so it's not know
we're ending but of course in the
computation there is there are links
there are multiplications matrix
multiplications Psalms many things so
now so what can we do of course we can
take the control points and compute the
coefficients in interval arithmetic we
know interval arithmetic so if we do
this I will present represent the
control points as intervals next I
compute in the same way the second
derivatives
it's something around here and these are
the coefficients and their intervals so
now the exact values of the coefficients
for these control points are in these
intervals and the next is to compute the
Rayleigh quotient in interval
mathematics
so it's this and we get some interval
here you can see that in the integration
I divided the integration not only into
that n intervals but each of those
intervals into M smaller intervals
because there is that non constant
weight so we are represented by
intervals so to make it more narrow you
can divide it it's not the only option
but it is possible and we get this
interval with 4 for cubic functions and
thousand subdivisions and we get this
interval and now the Rayleigh quotient
the exit value of the Rayleigh quotient
must be in this interval and the
relation is an upper estimate so the
right endpoint of this interval must be
a guaranteed upper estimate for the
principal value so this is the estimate
the our estimate and this was of course
if you want a better estimate you can
you can use more cubic fine cubic
functions this should last some 20 or 30
seconds and you get you get a better
number and you still can compare it to
either numerical approximation which is
denoted by lambda e estimated value 10
more seconds you can see if I if I add
more subdivisions more pieces of the
spline then the interval is in the first
case more narrow and the second case it
shifts left the problem is that of
course these four cubic functions would
be a function but it would mean
continuous and it's easy to find a
counter example where you get non
continuous function you compute the
Rayleigh quotient and you get a number
which is smaller than the principal
function the continuity there is
important so for that we have to compute
the intervals here so now you can see
that the error is 10 to minus 6 times
something and now the lower estimate the
last part which is a bit tricky I don't
have too much time but here you can see
what to do you if you want to to find a
lower estimate for this term you just
evaluate it as intervals but what must
happen here you see the result the first
the principal value is smaller as is
bigger or equal to minus infinity which
is true but it's not very useful so the
reason is of course that you have V in
the denominator and V is 0 at the end
and if you if you represent the values
of this function as interval the
interval must contain 0 and it also
contains negative numbers so all
possible ratios
go to minus infinity so what can we do
now we have to use a little bit
different test function one here it's
what I said that if you divide by
interval containing zero you get nothing
from minus infinity to plus infinity and
one possible solution is to shift the
test function by a positive constant
which can be done and not further our
estimate there you need to have a
function which is zero at the endpoints
but further lower estimate it's enough
that is positive inside the interval and
it doesn't have to be zero at the ends
so you can shift it so it's better it's
not minus infinity but it's some
negative number near zero why of course
it had to happen because we have second
derivative in the numerator and it's
also zero at the endpoints so you don't
get minus in minus infinity but
something close to zero and then
negative which is also useless so what
can we do if you compute the spine yeah
if you compute the spine you can choose
the second derivative at the ends so you
can choose them to be negative so minus
1/4 would be positive and then it would
be okay so I have I wanna try to to show
here a picture so this I already showed
so this is redefining the the
coefficients with the shift
and here you get our estimate near to
seven and I will show it on the picture
so we have several parameters here so
you can see that this is the shift so if
the shift is enough that at the
endpoints it doesn't go to minus
infinity now it's not minus infinity
right sorry
and this is the second derivative at the
endpoints so you can see what happens
that you get some estimate from law or
not speak about details on a half time
so I think I thank you for attention for
the moment there's any question two
minutes
yeah I think the control points as exact
numbers and then I must compute the
coefficients in interval arithmetic so
it's not I don't know if I can say that
it's closed forum but the exact
coefficients must be in those intervals
and I must compete with them as interest
that so all the very potion and also
this fraction must be that computed in
interval Mattox I want you to show that
it's much harder to get near to the but
it's clear it's the same as the first
computation that I showed so no more
questions thank you very much
[Applause]